night city was intended to be the city
to surpass all
other cities and the coastal california
metropolis has certainly lived up to
that reputation
for better and worse in this episode
we'll look closer at the varied
districts of the city
specifically the seven that you'll be
exploring in cyberpunk 2077
first up we've got city center that's
capital c capital c not the city center
though as you'd imagine it is indeed at
the core of night city
peppered with towering skyscrapers this
part of the city is punctuated by its
brutalist
architecture sea of neon lights and
menacing fortifications
mega screens light up the busy streets
and office buildings that form the
commercial hub of the city
after the fourth corporate war and the
ensuing nuclear fallout at arasaka tower
the zone was decimated
it was restored between the 2030s to the
2070s at great cost to the city
and now stands as a corporate stronghold
the centre of which is corporate plaza
home to some of the region's biggest
corporations including arasaka
militech biotechnica petrochem and kang
tao
its main feature is the memorial park an
enormous roundabout built to memorialize
those lost in the fourth corporate war
that also serves as a hub to connect
each corporation's headquarters
if corporate plaza is where you go to
make paper then its next door neighbor
downtown is where you'd go to spend it
flooded with exclusive nightclubs
expensive restaurants
chic bars and dozens of alleyways
there's plenty to do after dark
the northern waterfront area is home to
galleries concert halls and ateliers so
it's a common location for spotting the
rich and famous
it's not anywhere near as safe as its
sister sub-district city centre
though that's not something the ncpd
likes to advertise
a region that didn't receive anywhere
near as much reconstruction support
after the damage caused by the 2023
nuclear disaster is
watson located northwest of city centre
watson was once a cultural hotspot
dotted with nightclubs skyscrapers
and the biggest black market in the city
but these days it's run down
home to the more destitute inhabitants
of night city and dominated by the
maelstrom and tiger claws gangs all that
said it's also your home in night city
well v's home so i guess you'd better
get used to it watson was taken over by
the arasaka corporation
after the unification war and set up
shop on the waterfront for its port
access
they also built a wall around the
waterfront to keep the gangers
scavengers and reporters out of the
subdistrict
the once prosperous north side
industrial district is now the major
settlement of the maelstrom gang
while the tiger claws have taken over
little china little china used to be an
offshoot of downtown and it still shares
the skyscrapers and density of that
sub-district
it gathered its name from the large
groups of asian immigrants who moved
into it most of whom were from chinese
heritage
the sub-district used to be your
one-stop shop for legal body
augmentations and top
quality medical clinics but now it's a
mishmash of casinos strip clubs eating
dens offices and illegal gambling
parlors
all featuring a distinct chinese
aesthetic and bathed in neon glow
the nearby kabuki was originally a
flourishing sub-district due to the
japanese medical corporations it housed
but it's since fallen into disrepair and
has become just about the poorest
sub-district in night city
kabuki is marked by its twisting
claustrophobic alleyways
traditional chinese lanterns and bright
neon lights
that said for certain night city
residents kabuki is the place to be
and you can find plenty of
establishments here including the
infamous solos bar
afterlife it has an active underground
black market scene
entirely illegal of course where nothing
is off the menu for the right price
there's also plenty of clinics tucked
away in the corners of the district
where you can pick up illegal military
and prototype cyberware that's been
lifted from the labs of chiba city
the busy underground scene makes kabuki
the perfect hunting ground for scavs
a gang who kidnaps civilians and
harvests their organs and implants for
resale
maelstrom and the tiger claws both have
a presence in the area
but the mocks are the big dogs of kabuki
they hold control of
lizzie's bar one of the most popular
brain dance clubs and brothels in the
area
on the other end of the socio-economic
spectrum and a little to the east is the
lux district of westbrook
home to night city's elite and the
city's sizable japanese community
japan town isn't just a cultural hub for
the town though
it's also home to a shinto temple love
hotels host desk clubs and fancy
restaurants
it's also the main base of the tiger
claws gang who rule the district after
dark
located right by corpo plaza japan town
is a popular entertainment hub
with plenty of destinations for brain
dance enthusiasts discerning foodies and
everyone in between outside of the
hustle and bustle of japan town are
north oak and charter hill
north oak is the more prestigious of the
two where the highest class citizens are
protected by private security forces
day and night tree-lined streets are
dotted with sprawling villas luxury cars
and beautiful
people you'd never know that over 50
years prior the sub district was nothing
but arid hills on the border of night
city
charter hill doesn't quite reach north
oaks level of opulence but it's your pit
stop on the way
home to aspiring corporate fortunate
freelancers and musicians that are yet
to truly make it big
charter hill was the place to be before
north oak took the top spot
and it's the location of choice for the
upper middle class
sprawling over the center of night city
to the east of city centre is heywood a
district of disparity
toward the north are lush green parks
and towering skyscrapers
while the south is an urban jungle that
houses a sea of slums
the majority of night city residents
live in hayward and are spread amongst
its disparately high and
low-income housing a quality that gave
the district its reputation as
the biggest bedroom in night city the
safest part of haywood is wellsprings
the section which borders city center it
consists of mid to low-income housing
but is still far more desirable than
certain areas of night city
the eastern part of wellsprings is
littered with shanty houses and graffiti
from the valentino's gang
though that gang actually operates in a
separate subdistrict vista del rey
as the poorest district of haywood the
streets are marked by graffiti
crumbling buildings and the tension
between the valentinos and sixth street
gangs
though there's apparently also pretty
great tacos to be found so it's got that
going for it which is nice
finally haywood is also home to the glen
a sub-district that houses
reconciliation park
and the newly built city hall the glenn
is a small relatively lawful haven in a
district otherwise marred by the stark
contrast between the wealthy and
poverty-stricken
[Music]
in night city there's low-income housing
poverty slums and then
there's pacifica i won't mince words
here after the
economic collapse pacifica got
absolutely screwed
the far south district was originally
zoned to become a home away from home
vacation resort
set to bring sandy beaches luxury hotels
and vibrant nightlife to the lives of
hard-working night city residents
instead it was abandoned by the
corporations who had pledged to develop
it
and so the half-built dreamy tourist
escape stayed as it was
and degraded into a district that those
who have nowhere else to go
find themselves pacifica is split up
into west wind estate and coast
view the voodoo boys gang make their
home here having taken it upon
themselves to take care of the locals
who've been left for dead by the ncpd
they also make it clear outsiders are
not welcome
landmarks of the district include the
grand imperial mall which
just like everything else in the
district lies unfinished and half
constructed
it's since become the stomping grounds
of the animals gang
pacifica also includes a number of
half-finished and abandoned
hotels including the rindo hotel and
baddies hotel
they now serve as the residences for the
local homeless population
the ncpd have labelled the district's
threat level catastrophic
and marked it as a no-go combat zone
where law enforcement is limited or
non-existent
scavengers are also known to frequent
pacifica making it somehow even more
dangerous
the final district we'll be covering
that's actually in night city is one of
the oldest zones
santo domingo located way out east santo
domingo largely serves as a testing
ground for industrial projects
the sub-district reo is in a constant
state of construction
it houses the arasaka factory petrochem
better life's power plants
and a sprawling junkyard among other
things the sixth street gang
also operates in this sub-district and
controls a number of abandoned factories
in the area
the neighboring sub-district of rancho
coronado contains most of the
residential dwellings of the area
it's largely suburban featuring
identical 1950s style houses on
tree-lined streets
manikin lawns and family oriented living
and entertainment areas
the entire district including the
residential areas are under the control
of the corporations who develop within
them
making it into a sort of corporate
utopia
[Music]
last but not least outside of night city
are the badlands which are populated by
nomads
ex-corpos have been blackballed from
employment and now roam the outskirts of
the city mad max style
nomads share the land with the wraiths
gang a group made up of exiles from
local tribes and their families
the northern sector features unchecked
resource extraction and derelict oil
fields
the east is marked by landfills where
acid rains threaten
any vegetation that attempts to survive
and the south is dominated by a vast
desert
though biotechnica's protein farms and
the jackson plains power plant can also
be found here
it's pretty much the wild west out in
the badlands so don't expect a safe
journey wherever you're traveling to
while there's plenty more details to be
mined from cyberpunk 2020 that should
give you a pretty good idea of the
regions you'll be questing through in
cyberpunk 2077.
as always let us know what other law
topics you'd like to see covered in our
next video
be sure to check out our previous
episodes and we'll see you again soon
you